so let's talk about what actually causes
an autoimmune condition let me just
briefly tell you what an autoimmune
condition is it's a situation where your
body has created immune cells that are
attacking itself and that creates
inflammation and inflammation creates a
lot of collateral damage and it's all
those free radicals that end up
destroying the tissue and the immune
cells that are attacking itself are
called Auto antibodies and you can have
these Auto antibodies to pretty much any
tissue in your body you can have them to
receptors of cells you can have these
immune cells attack pretty much any
tissue of the body and so what an
autoimmune condition boils down to is
this one cell called the th17 cell
becoming over active okay excessive
amounts of the T it's called helper cell
17 are responsible for autoimmune
conditions so now let me just kind of
explain what this cell is in your immune
system you have a lot of different
players and you have different types of
T cells and the T stands for thymus
because that's where it gets its
training and that's where it matures and
develops and typically the T helper
cells have to do with command control
they're like the quarterback or the
general that recruits help for infection
that generates the weapon tree-like
cytokines in the inflammatory process so
it's the main controller of the battle
with infections so it's a real key
element when someone's infected with the
HIV virus what that virus does is it
targets the T helper cells and it knocks
those guys out so you have no more
immune system at all well in an
autoimmune condition you have an over
activation of these cells right here
th17 cells one of the functions of these
cells is to maintain in the intestinal
barrier okay the barrier between
microbes pathogens and the inside of the
body
I'm talking about the lymph nodes
capillaries the vascular system so it's
really the maintaining of that barrier
and also to help maintain the microbiome
homeostasis so to keep those microbes
from invading the inside of the body
because if there's a break in the wall
and these bacteria get across and invade
the inside of your body and then you're
gonna get an immune attack and your
body's going to start creating
antibodies against those cells if some
of those cells are pathogens that's a
good thing but what if those cells are
your own cells that would be a bad thing
so part of the t-cells are involved in
central tolerance which means tolerating
itself in other words it's
differentiating itself from a pathogen
it's making sure that we don't end up
destroying our own tissue this cell
helps prevent autoimmune conditions now
it also works with the T regulatory
cells which has an even greater function
of preventing autoimmune diseases and it
also has a suppressive function of
suppressing autoimmune diseases and
suppressing hyper inflammatory condition
so anything that's too much inflammation
it tends to calm that system down so if
there's an infection involved and you go
through this whole infection the T
regulatory cells they're also called T
suppressor cells go in there and put the
fire out and calm down the infection so
when this cell doesn't work like it
should now you're going to get a
movement of bacteria across that
intestinal barrier and you're going to
get chronic infection and you're gonna
get a lot of inflammation and that's
really what's behind the autoimmune
disease but now the question is how do
these cells become over activated well
they don't know that but they do know
there's several things involved we know
there's usually a microbe involved some
infection by some virus or some other
microbe
there's also associations with stress
so that could activate cortisol which
also weakens this barrier right here and
then we also have malnutrition that
factor and I'm talking about vitamin D
now what's so interesting about vitamin
D is that vitamin D helps this cell
directly it can help to bring down this
over reaction of this sound and this is
why vitamin D even in the 40s was used
for rheumatoid arthritis and I'm talking
like 200,000 to 400,000 international
units of vitamin D to put that condition
in remission so vitamin D helps to
regulate the T helper cells specifically
this one that's involved in autoimmune
disease if you have an autoimmune
condition you should be taking vitamin D
and you definitely need to focus in and
do research on that area and I have some
real interesting links down below so
check them out thanks for watching hey
well back with another amazing recipe no
brains no sugar
totally Kido
there's no suffering and Keita
absolutely no character and it's an
immune system absolutely you have to
check this out I think you should hurry
up watch the recipe and make it yourself
it's just so easy to be keto but is it
simple it's super simple
we hope you enjoy making it as much as
we are enjoying eating